There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
This is the Super Saturated
serum from Experiment.
It has 30% glycerin in it,
which I think is what makes it so sticky.
This is supposed to be a hydrating serum,
but I'm going to be using
it as a makeup primer.
It reminds me so much of all
those sticky, tacky primers
on the market right now,
like the one from Milk.
This actually felt amazing on my skin.
It's kind of slimy, but it
just feels so hydrating.
I let it sit for a bit before
applying my foundation on top,
and everything went on really nicely.
It's so similar to other
sticky primers I've tried,
but this is more of a skincare product.
I'm definitely going to keep
using this as a primer, though.
I don't know how, but I
managed to get my hands
on the One/Size blush
trio in Attention Seeker.
It has a cream, a matte
powder, and a sheen powder.
I've reviewed these
before and did love them,
but the cream in this one is just not it.
It's so chalky and ashy looking.
I get that not every color
is going to work for every skin tone,
but the creams in the
other colors I've tried
were much more true to how
they looked in the pan.
The matte powder blush is really pretty.
Combining the matte blush
with the cream blush
gave me such a better color payoff,
but the sheen powder is the
real star of the show here.
It has a bunch of pink, baby blue,
and lavender shimmer in it
that just looks so beautiful.
I had to put this on my eyes too.
I loved it so much.
This is the Iconic London
Rollaway Glow highlighter.
It's literally a roll-on highlighter.
When I first applied it,
I did go over already-powdered makeup
and realized that this stuff
dries down almost immediately.
Like, it simply would not blend.
So I tried it again over
not-powdered makeup.
I worked section by section,
and I also tried to
move at lightning speed,
and I had a much better outcome.
I feel like it still dried down so fast.
I had to blend for a while to
get it to look how I wanted,
but I do think it's very pretty and glowy.
Fenty Beauty released another lip product.
This is the Icon velvet liquid lipstick.
The packaging is so cool.
Look at this little floating logo.
The formula is this super-mousse-y cream.
It doesn't dry down like a
regular liquid lipstick would.
It just stays this soft
matte finish on the lips.
These are really pigmented.
Like, the color is so rich,
and they feel so comfortable
and pillowy on the lips.
I've seen people say that
these transfer a lot.
They're not described
as being transfer-proof,
but I do see how this formula
could move around throughout the day.
I think a good lip liner and
some blotting could help.
But honestly, I really like
how this formula feels and looks.
I have two very similar
products to compare,
the Essence What a Tint lip and cheek tint
and the Benefit Benetint.
Both are this watery pink lip stain
that you can also use on the cheeks,
but the Essence one is
just way more affordable.
I have to say I didn't
really like either of these
on top of foundation.
I feel like they both
lifted my foundation a bit
and looked a little patchy.
The Benetint did have a
better color payoff, though.
But then on the lips,
I feel like the Essence
one was more pigmented.
It was very confusing.
Both looked patchy on my lips as well.
They are similar enough, though,
that you could save the money
and go for the Essence one.
This is the Make Up for
Ever HD Skin matte velvet
undetectable longwear
blurring powder foundation.
These names, you guys.
They're just getting longer and longer.
I'm always a little scared
of powder foundations
because I feel like they tend
to grab on to dryness and texture,
but I was completely blown away by this.
This powder is silky
smooth and just glides on.
I don't understand how they
got a powder foundation
to look this natural on the skin.
Ugh, it's just so beautiful!
And it smoothed out all my problem areas.
The coverage is also buildable.
My other makeup went on
top of this really nicely.
I even did concealer over the powder,
and it blended out just fine.
This is a new favorite for me.
This is the Kaja Jelly Charm
glazed lip stain and blush.
It comes with this supercute key chain.
This feels really nice
and hydrating on the lips,
but I don't think it has
a great color payoff.
The stain it leaves behind
is also pretty subtle.
I don't think this is a
serious cheek product.
It's almost, like, too
glossy to be a blush,
and it lifted a lot of the
product I already had on.
MAC just released this
Locked Kiss Ink lipstick.
It's a transfer-proof
and waterproof lipstick
that's meant to last a really long time.
The actual formula is more
watery than I was expecting.
It's on the thinner side and
does need some time to dry
if you need to add more.
It's very lightweight and not drying,
even though it is matte.
I wore this for about six hours.
I drank and ate,
and it still looked good
at the end of the day.
I also did a kiss test on the
back of my hand and on my dog,
and I definitely think
this is transfer-proof.
I'm seeing formulas like
this everywhere nowadays,
so this isn't really
special, but it does work.
I think the Patrick Ta
Major Glow highlighting mist
was one of the first products
to ever be released by the brand,
but I've never tried it.
This is essentially a
highlighter in a can.
I got the duo, which
comes with a mini mist
and this fan to help you get
a more precise application.
I do think the glow
this gives is beautiful,
but it's obviously hard to control a mist,
even with the fan,
so I ended up getting
highlighter in a lot of places.
For now, I can see myself using
this as a body highlighter.
I still need more practice
with it on the face,
but I do like how it looks on the skin.
I've used a few of the Rare Beauty
Soft Pinch liquid blushes before,
but only the matte formulas,
and I've never used a shade this vibrant.
This is the color Lucky,
and it's a dewy hot pink.
I actually found this dewy formula
to be a little bit easier to work with
because it doesn't dry down as fast.
This product in general needs
a bit of trial and error.
For me, the easiest way to work with it
is to apply some on the back of my hand,
blend that with a sponge,
and then gently tap it onto the face.
It does layer nicely over other products,
and you can pick your level of intensity
as long as you don't
immediately go in with too much.
This is one of those colors
that I can see working
for so many people,
and I actually think I
prefer the dewy formula.
This is the Makeup by Mario
MoistureGlow plumping lip color.
It's supposed to be
full coverage, plumping,
and weightless on the lips.
I would say it's one
of those three things.
It is super moisturizing
and feels good on the lips,
but unfortunately, the
coverage was really streaky.
I had to do a couple layers
to give me the coverage I wanted.
It was settling a little bit in my lines.
I also didn't see or
feel any plumping effect.
I do want to try a more nude shade
to see if those are any better,
but for right now, I think
this is just an OK lip gloss.
This is the Glow Recipe
strawberry BHA pore-smooth Blur Drops.
You can use this as a serum or a primer.
On my bare skin,
I can definitely see some blurring,
especially in the area by my nose
where I feel like I have
the most visible pores.
However, as a primer,
I absolutely hate this.
I used products I know work well
and look great every single time.
But on top of this primer,
everything was just looking bad.
My makeup was so patchy,
and it made my products pill up.
I can see myself using this
to help me control my oil
on my no-makeup days,
but as a primer, absolutely not.
I've been seeing these "angel
wing" lashes all over TikTok
and really wanted to try them.
If you've ever seen me apply fake lashes,
you know I'm terrible at it.
But this style is so cute to me.
It's very Disney princess.
I don't particularly
like this brand of lash
because the band was
just too thick and stiff,
but I do like the lash style.
Too Faced came out with these
Lip Injection Extreme Lip
Shaper plumping lip liners.
I'm actually a fan
of their Lip Injection
Extreme Lip Plumpers.
It does have a pretty
intense tingly feeling,
just like the plumpers,
but I really enjoyed these.
They work exactly the same
as the regular plumpers,
except I think these are better.
With lip plumpers, you're
supposed to apply a little bit
outside of your lip line
for a plumping effect.
And since these are plumping lip liners,
it just makes it so easy.
I like that you can define
and plump at the same time.
I'm holding on to these for sure.
This is the NYX Face Freezie
cooling hydration moisturizer and primer.
It has this really
interesting gel texture.
I typically don't like primers like this,
but it blended into my skin quickly
and it definitely
blurred some of my pores.
It has a cooling effect
that feels really good.
I thought I would have an
issue applying my other makeup
on top of a primer like this,
but I actually loved how my makeup looked.
Everything blended out
easily and looked so smooth.
I don't think I would use this
as an everyday moisturizer,
but I do like this as a primer.
I've used the Maybelline
Instant Age Rewind Eraser for years,
but never in this pink shade
that recently went viral.
This is the shade 160 Brightener.
I just put a bit under each
eye before my concealer.
The second I started blending it out,
it brightened so much.
Next time, I think I would
go in with a little less
because it's an intense brightener,
but I think it looked OK
once I applied my concealer on top.
The Instant Age Rewind formula
has always been really good.
My concealer always creases eventually
because I have a lot of lines,
but once this concealer dries,
my creasing is so minimal.
It also had great coverage,
even before I applied my concealer.
This is the new Milk Makeup Pore Eclipse
mattifying and blurring setting spray.
It's supposed to give
you a soft-focus finish
and control oil,
something I definitely need help with.
I really like the mist on this.
It's super fine.
I feel like I noticed a soft-focus effect
after setting my makeup.
It is a little too matte-looking for me.
I like a little bit of dewiness.
But it didn't make my
makeup look dry or crusty.
I did a check-in about five hours later
and was actually really impressed
with how it controlled my oil.
My nose and my forehead
are usually so oily
within a few hours, but
I still looked matte
and all of the makeup was
still visible on my face.